all right it's that time of the week
it's time for hatred mail because it's
time to make America hate again Patriot
mail written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom what I can tell you is that this
week's hatred has really strong opinions
about something I don't know what but
they are very clearly trying to make a
point about which they feel very
strongly let's see we can figure out
what that point is take a listen David
Pakman you are the definition of hate
can't decide who is more ignorant David
Pakman are the viewers who see it week
on the facts ignorant and proud of it
Parkman sad you are just a typical
smarmy liberal Killary losers don't
that's exactly right
Killary losers don't they don't what it
reminded me of this funny phrase that
used to go around the internet where
people would put I accidentally the
whole thing and it looks like there's a
word missing and the obvious reaction is
you accidentally what the whole thing
Hillary losers don't what I don't know
what this refers to Pat yeah and it's
not even like you're on Twitter here I
mean you have plenty of characters this
is an email you can write as much as you
want finish the thought
yeah there was no you weren't being
charged per character mister hey tree
and I say mister because obviously hey
tree it's our men you can use the coupon
code hey tree at 42 save 40% off of a
membership and five hey tree it's cry
every time you use the coupon code hey
tree at forty at join pakman.com you go
to join pakman.com pick your membership
coupon code h80
our iot for zero chops 40% off of your
membership really upsets the hey treats
which we love